SUVs are certainly very popular these
days
and they're making car makers a pile of
money Renault launched its first SUV in
2015 the Koch are the models roots
however go back to the year 2006
thank today thanks to the alliance with
Misun explains our car man Andre Renault
was able to build on the tried and
tested Qashqai as it sought to enter the
compact SUV market but there are no Kjar
is not a clone of the Qashqai for one
thing it is seven centimeters longer and
four centimetres wider and inside the
dashboard is very different and much
nicer from Castilla
it's not always the case that the cabins
of models that share a platform are
significantly different from one another
the drive technology is from the Qashqai
we tested the 1.6 liter DCI 130 the only
version that offers all-wheel drive SUVs
are rarely driven off-road these days so
all-wheel drive is no longer a given
this car the Bose Edition list said just
under thirty four thousand four hundred
euros in Germany
demote Wanda Renault says the kadjar
offers dynamic motoring fun whatever the
engine that certainly holds true for the
diesel version that Andre is testing at
2,000 rpm you feel a surge of power that
qualifies the sports utility vehicle as
sporty I'm sports utility vehicle
do shots are fun
as for the styling the kadjar is duly
chunky even bullish with a high ground
clearance matte plastic suggests robust
ruggedness what sets this model apart is
its unusual curviness
the controls for the air conditioning
have a very nice unlike look the sat-nav
is definitely Renault
the cruise control switch is in an odd
place behind the handbrake
do not spit an SUV has to demonstrate
some utility in the kadjar that is
evident in the back seats they are roomy
enough for tall people and comfortable
the trunk is also spacious and a match
for rival models taking it can pack in
some 472 liters of cargo
the infotainment the infotainment system
supports a range of connectivity
standards among the options you can use
your own smartphone navigation app or
music streaming services and for many
potential buyers the Bose sound system
is a nice extra a few the optional ahead
was the sound unlockable item the kadjar
offers what might be termed a typically
French ride instead of firm and sporty
the suspension is son the shocks do
plenty of absorbing on rough roads the
steering is smooth but it hardly lets
you feel the road
no catch there were no cut shark clearly
demonstrates the transformation that
SUVs have gone through instead of
stylish off-roaders they're now more the
new family car and that's where the
kadjar stands out it's roomy and it's
comfortable even for longer trips that's
a sound choice for a family vacation for
Denise the Wallops Kaiser